no
[Música]
yo represento el sentimiento de muchos
de los que estamos hoy en día en el
anonimato olvidados porque fuimos
utilizados
para esos intereses en defensa de la
bandera de estados
[Música]
utilizaremos estas opiniones
no
un nivel muy alto de
profesionalismo que los contratistas 690
de nuestra misión
[Música]
lo ven a uno como si fuera basura que la
vida de uno no es considerada para nada
como si uno no fuera un ser humano como
si uno fuera un perro yo tengo
experiencia de guerra en colombia estuve
en sitios hostiles como toribío cauca y
enfrente del sexto frente de las farc y
la verdad nunca había visto algo como
esto nunca fui entrenado para hacer
carne de cañón o para estar afuera
esperando un enemigo mucho más avanzado
o fuerte
[Música]